foreign
[Music]
my name is Mark ducop I'm the CEO and
co-founder of novazine and today I'm
going to talk about process modeling so
my talk will be entitled from
experiments data Hybrid models and
digital twins several up and downstream
success stories highlighting the
benefits of using advanced process
modeling
before we start with this topic I
quickly want to introduce myself again
or the company I'm working for so as
said we founded an oversign it's a
spin-off from Book University in Vienna
Book University of Nevada has a
department of Biotech for biotechnology
already since 30 years in the last 10
years we intensively focused on process
modeling and from this knowledge we
gained in this field basically we
founded the company in 2019 mainly
addressing early stage was the
development to speed up the development
process by reducing the experimental
effort and during the talk I will show
you some highlights from our work this
is all published so you will always find
to the bottom right there's uh there's a
quote which you can then go to the
internet and basically search for this
publication if you have more if you're
more interested in more details or you
can also write me in an email afterwards
okay so starting off uh uh how can we
basically what do we need to have better
bio processes so first of all we have to
understand our buyer processes better so
that means we have to describe them in a
certain way in a certain qbd approach so
that we basically better understand how
input and output is connected the second
thing is basically that we need better
process scaling so you know this
basically we need to process upscale you
often have the issue that whatever you
develop in the smaller scale the ideal
set points do not hold true in the
larger scale and the third thing
basically what we want to do when we
look into the future is we also want to
have process control so basically we
want to interact with our process and in
case that something goes wrong we want
to know which screws to turn in order to
develop in order to get the process in
the right direction again for example to
maintain a certain quality attributes or
a certain title or whatever just to
bring it back and all of these three
things as you might notice are a
modeling topics so basically if you use
nice models you can have a process
understanding you can use these models
for process scale up and also you need
models for process control so that
basically with Nova sand where we have
division is basically to create a hybrid
modeling toolbox and we're going to
detail afterwards what is hybrid
modeling but the idea is to have this
hybrid modeling toolbox and this
basically is set by experimental data so
you have to perform experiment in a
certain way you have to feed this
information into the toolbox the toolbox
then learns from this information and
basically gives the process engineer the
understanding of how input and output is
connected that's the first thing and
that's it afterwards when we also want
to use these models not only for
understanding and for optimization but
also for control purposes we also have
to bring it back to the to the
manufacturing environment where we use
this type of models for process
monitoring and control purposes
today's talk I will have six showcases
for you for Upstream showcases and two
Downstream showcases and we're basically
all developed in this hybrid modeling
toolbox we will also be a link provided
at the end where you can download this
toolbox and you can test it yourself on
your own data together and the idea of
how this works
basically it helps you to get it helps
you to develop time resolved buyer
process models
gives you a certain process knowledge
that helps you to understand how input
and output is connected and you can take
these models for process optimization
and asset afterwards for control
purposes and already quite some
pharmaceutical companies use this tool
to optimize their processes
before I want to start with the modeling
task I want to highlight one really
crucial things because we always
encounter this that a lot of people
believe that the algorithms are the only
important thing to drive a valuable
process model but it's actually not so
the first thing before you start
modeling before you do anything is
questioning yourself what do you want to
do what is your what is the whole
modeling task for you wanted to process
optimization do you want to have a model
for process control what is the purpose
of all of this model based on that you
can then think about which experiments
to perform so what are the critical
process parameters I'm looking at you
can do this with a um with a risk
analysis for example to investigate
which of the factors are really
important and which are less important
than you think about how which
experiment to perform
afterwards you collect the data and when
I say collecting the data we're
collecting the offline and the online
data because there's value in both of
them and only after that's left we are
then going in the direction of process
modeling so the first step the third
step then is process modeling is not
just about about the algorithm but it's
really about the research question what
do you want to do then building the type
of experiments data process modeling and
based on that you can then use this
these models in a digital twin
environment where you can do in silica
process simulation to say okay what
would be my ideal process condition and
then you either go back to the lab and
perform your experiments or oh this is a
little bit off you take these models
basically for for scaling or for
manufacturing for visualization you can
take this type of models then for for
the for the error for the second for the
for the green line here
when we talk about Hybrid models what
does this mean basically are Hybrid
models bridge the gap between
mechanistic understanding and data so as
we said we have to have a certain
understand we have to have a certain
idea what we want to predict from our
models what is the what is the the
output in this case we want to have
critical equality articles one and two
this one should be predicted by the
model and we have some critical process
parameters that that fit into this model
and then we have a mixture of a black
box the machine learning part
artificial neural network for example
and this is an artificial neural
networks and predicts or estimates some
rates that are then put into mechanistic
understanding so like a mass balances
which then at the end predict the
critical quality attributes and by doing
so you have the advantage that you have
a precise identification with a smaller
amount of experiments you can use this
knowledge for process scale up and as I
said you can use the same type of models
for monitoring and control and all of
this showcases I will show you today in
detail for up and downstream topics
when talking about hybrid model what is
the what is the advantage of using
hybrid model so for example this is our
this is one of the first Publications
here I want to share with you today the
link is down there to the right what you
basically see here is we were interested
into describing a design space a
three-dimensional design space in a 20
liter microbial fermentation and we
wanted to describe basically how the
cells react to different inputs
based on an ordinary doe endpoint
description uh based on the Black Box
modeling and based on hybrid modeling
and when we do so and we compare it
basically to predict the biomass and to
predict the product at the end you see
here that the error for the for the
response surface model with a with an
ordinary OLS model is basically very
accurate in the range of the analytical
error and so it's the hybrid model but
the hybrid model has the advantage that
you model in this case the entire
process from the beginning until the end
you also capture the process Dynamics
and you incorporate knowledge that is a
lot of advantages and the errors in a
very similar range when you now look at
the product basically you see that the
error coming from uh from the OLS model
is in the range of 20 while the error
from the hybrid model is in the range of
10 the reason why is basically that with
the hybrid model we are connect the
product formation to the specific to the
to the biomass so the more we know how
much biomass we have in our system the
better we can predict how much product
is expected at the end point and
therefore we get the best a better
Precision with this hybrid model over
the over the other two the one I did not
mention so far is the Pure Black Box
model so it basically also describes the
whole process in a Time resolved manner
but the accuracy is not as high as from
the hybrid model
and by doing so you can do
multi-dimensional optimization so you
basically get one model to predict or to
describe as many output parameters you
want to have in this case we only have
product and biomass we could also for
example think about product quality you
could also model glucose propagation
over time all of these factors could be
taken into account and they are all in
this singing model that describes the
whole process at once second due to the
fact that you have this time resource
model you can then think about advanced
screening methods like this intensified
design of experiment approach I will go
into detail afterwards but in a nutshell
basically it just helps you to
significantly reduce
your amount of experiments to screen a
certain design space and finally uh the
model structure I said Can directly be
taken for monitoring and control because
yeah you just have to put the input
parameters in and then you get a
prediction for the output parameters
you're basically interested in
so these are the six showcases I want to
show you today for Upstream showcases
into Downstream showcases starting
directly with the Upstream showcase it's
about model based process optimization
so here the idea is to start with a
certain amount of experiment with a
small amount of experiments and then as
quickly as possible screening the whole
design space to find the optimum with as
little experimental effort as possible
so as that idea risk you have to think
about what do I want to predict what are
the critical process formats I want to
vary then you start with an initial
guess
you perform your experiment you create
your hybrid model and then you go into
this in silico simulator
which then basically simulates all of
the possible combination in this design
space
based on that the system tells you an
Optimum so what is the best favorable
condition you can you can have and then
you you look basically if you already
performed this experiment
or or if it's a new Optimum when it's a
new Optimum that means you have to
perform this experiment because you you
don't know it from the data yet and once
you perform this experiment you
basically take it into account and put
it again into the model structure and
then you're in this iterative Loop and
you just iterate through the design
space until the moment where you don't
get a new Optimum so basically your your
tools that's okay this is the this is
the condition which is favorable and
then if you look and you already
performed this experiment you know that
you're basically you found the optimum
and by doing so you can Screen through
the design space and with this
duplication here for example we could
reduce the experimental F4 127
experiments to screen the whole design
space down to nine by by using this uh
model based design of experimental
approach and you can see this here in
detail for example so we started a set
with five initial experiments and then
we just iterated through the design
space along these orange dots and then
found the optimum in this case we
modeled space-time yield and you can see
for example in the first iteration where
we only have five experiments
you see that the model is already very
accurately describing the biomass let's
see this in green
but it's quite off for the for the
product so it means you take this
experiment P into account into the next
iteration put it into the algorithm and
do the same thing again and again and
again
and after iteration F basically you
finish this optimization and you found
your your Optimum process condition and
but doing so you can iterate through the
design space if you have the ability to
perform campaigns for example that you
can perform for experiment at the time
because you have a task key for
an ember system or something like that
and you can also think about what would
be the four best conditions to learn as
much as possible from the design space
to iterate through your Optimum to your
Optimum so that is the first thing I
wanted to share with you again here
there's the publication on there just
follow the link uh and and read it in
detail if you're if you're interested so
that's the that's the first thing I
wanted to show you here when it's about
process optimization you don't have a
lot of ideas about your process and you
just start with some initial experiments
the second showcase I want to share with
you is uh it's about process
characterization
so it's more about uh you have a defined
design space you want to screen and here
you can use something like intensified
design of experiments how does this
basically work uh you can have you have
several approaches how you can screen
the design space the the most easy so
let's say the obvious one is to just
perform one of the experiments that that
are possible if you have a very large
design space or something above four
factors this might turn infeasible
because you have to perform that many
experiment that you just cannot you will
never finish it
second one is obviously the obvious one
is then you reduce your experimental
effort by just taking out experiments
you see this in this fractional approach
where you just reduce the experimental
effort by just taking points out but
it's also quite clear that this comes
with the drawback that you not able to
describe the design space in the same
way because you significantly reduce the
amount of experiments and the third one
is this is the approach I want to
suggest here is this intensified design
of experiment abroads what you do is you
start with a certain parameter
combination so let's say to the corner
left and then during your cultivation
you change your process parameter
combination let's say to the center
point here and after a certain time
again you you change this parameter
combination again and by doing so it's
quite obvious that you can uh basically
put free x in this case put free
experimental parameter combination to
one experiment so you see that you only
perform nine experiments overall but you
pack 27 parameter combinations into a
single experiment into into pack three
parameter combinations into uh each
experiment that means you can screen 27
parameter combinations with only nine
experiments
and now when looking at the results
basically you see this here so we
created a hybrid model based on this
nine iron intensified design of
experiment runs which are these orange
dots and created the hybrid model and
then we took this model and applied it
to the static design of experimental
approach which is basically this uh
triangle as this green triangles and you
see this is a prediction of the model
over the measured values and you see
when you when you create the hybrid
model design ID reruns yeah for sure
it's quite precise because it's trained
on this data but then when you take
basically the static doe data so the
runs where you do not change any
parameter combinations the classical
approach let's say this way you see that
the hybrid model is able to predict the
outcome of the static runs quite
accurately so in a nutshell you can
think about okay either you perform
this 27 experiments or 31 because we we
did some replicates
or you perform nine experiments to
stream the design space and it's quite
obvious that the amount of work you have
to put into nine experiments is
significantly less compared to the 31
experiments are in the static and you
see on to the left is scatter plot and
in the center on the right there are
some there are free runs for example as
an example for static experiments with
different outcomes and different timings
and you can see how the hybrid model is
able to predict this outcome quite
accurately with the advantage that you
save almost 70 percent of experimental
effort and second which is maybe not so
obvious when you think about model
predictive control approaches where you
want to change process parameter
combination in order to recover your
process
you have to know basically how your
cells react to process changes and
somehow by applying this already during
the learning uh your model somehow
understands how quickly or how quickly
basically process parameter changes lead
to a certain quality change in your in
your responses
the third showcase I want to share with
you is a process scale up modeling here
in this case we took Cho culture and the
idea was to apply a model from Shake
class experiments and so to train a
model on Shake fast experiment and then
to apply it apply it on the 15 liter
scale so it's a factor of 50 scale up
and we wanted to predict basically how
good or we want to we want to apply the
knowledge from the small scale on the
larger scale to find the optimum process
condition on the larger scale
and the only thing we had to do in order
to be able to describe the full design
space on the larger scale was to take a
Center Point cultivation to recalibrate
the model on the larger scale and then
it was able to predict the outcome for
all of the different other parameter
combinations
you can basically see this here so you
have again the Scatter Plots to the left
side left side top left is basically uh
the viable cell density how how accurate
this is predicted for the for the shake
file experiment and to the left bottom
basically it's the product so you see
hybrid model was trained and this runs
quite accurately and then it was
predicting the outcome on the 15 liter
scale so it's a little bit less precise
but still it's also very good and you
see also that the model is now able to
describe much higher uh product
formations for example right to the left
the maximum was 0.6 grams per liter only
to the right it was one gram per late
and this was a this was possible just
because we did a recalibration of the
center point
took this information into the hybrid
model and then it was able to describe
this larger scale
also quite accurately
the last Upstream showcase here I want
to show you is basically then when you
have such a model so you now created
hybrid model we now save the
experimental effort on the larger scale
how can we now take these models for uh
process monitoring and control purposes
we have a collaboration together with
Siemens in Vienna and what we basically
did is we set up our Siemens setup yeast
cultivation in this bioreactor down
there
with a toe setup so to change pH and
temperature they also had some off guard
measurement
they perform this experiment sent us the
data we created a hybrid model and sent
them back basically the valuable
information so the the pack hybrid model
in the dll file so the dll file and
contains all of the knowledge of okay
what what what is the outcome if you
change one of these input vectors and
then they put it into the sideboard
environment and we're able to basically
monitor uh the gluco and sorry monitor
the biomass concentration in real time
during uh during next cultivations and
this is basically depicted here
so you see for example how the biomass
propagates uh over time in this disease
cultivation there was also there were
also some offline measurements but you
see that there are that the soft sensor
was working quite accurately and you can
you can use such type of substance for
manufacturing purposes for for example
induce yourself or without a certain uh
at a certain concentration to Reliable
always get the
similar output at the end of your
cultivation and this is a typical
application is that for for a soft
tension was implemented in the in the
living lab
in Siemens Indiana
the next thing I want to share with you
is an Downstream showcase and here is
about ultra filtration flux prediction
so what we want to do here is to predict
basically the duration of an
ultrafiltration process as accurately as
possible and the vision we had in mind
basically was to say okay we want to
have the process characterization of a
certain membrane with a certain product
we want to know in the whole design
Space by changing different parameter
combination how quickly can we finish
such a process and how does it propagate
depending on the input parameter so we
had a set of product and membrane
combination
and then we chose cleverly chose our
design space when you remember what I
told you in the beginning when I said
it's not only about the algorithm it's
also about the design space this is
really crucial the experiments are as
crucial as the as the as the as the
modeling approach itself so it's not
just the algorithm that will solve the
issue it's really about thinking about
which experiments you have to perform in
order to get the maximum out we often
see from customers when we were at the
University I think a lot of you also
have the same impression that it's
rather starting soon with some
experiments been thinking about what
would be the ideal experiment in the
language you think about how to perform
the ideal experiments the better your
initial guess already will be so I think
this is a really underestimated
underestimated parameter so think about
your experiments as as much as possible
before you start them in with respect to
what you want to deliver at the end
uh
when the last thing we want to do here
is basically to take this model stand
once we have to design space we want to
take these models for
um to predict the outcome of batch tff
that batch dff single passing Edge for
filtration entire filtration so that we
have one model that is able to describe
all of these four different uh unit
operations or operational modes in a
single model
uh when thinking about the fat patch
model basically what we did here is we
we changed uh the three parameter
combinations we were interested in is
the TMP uh the the cross flow and the
starting concentration of our of our of
our tiger protein and then we let an
estimate we let an artificial neural
network predict basically the flux at
each parameter combination and then we
put this flux into the mass balance and
based on this mass balance basically a
new concentration was predicted after a
certain in time interval and then we
take this we take this new concentration
and basically put it back into the into
the iterative loop and by doing so you
can get a multi-step ahead prediction
and you can predict basically the
duration of the process or the outcome
at the pros of this process depending on
your input parameters and this is a very
simple but clever structure in order to
uh to model such a such a process
and when we now look at the results we
see here for example the duration of
such uh of such a batch tff or fat batch
tff for you maybe to recap the
difference between a batch and the fat
batch tff is a search tank so any for
example are in the manufacturing side
and you have let's say a five liter tank
or a 10 liter tank but you have 20
liters to process you need to put this
remaining 10 liter somewhere and this
would be put into a such tank so that
means it's something like a dire
filtration but you're diluting it with
with your original protein concentration
the consequence is that you see
basically the uh the shape of the
profile is completely different but due
to this hybrid modeling approach and due
to the fact that we could take this
knowledge and we know how this works and
put it into the into the mechanistic
equations we are able to predict those
different uh operational modes and you
see here for example five models for
five different protein concentration you
see that the model and the predictions
are quite accurate in predicting the
duration of how long function process
would take as a function of the input
parameters and you see the same for the
batch dff and you see the same for the
fat batch tff yarn
in the second step or in the next step
basically you can take the same type of
model so you can take the same training
data to predict basically the duration
or to predict the conversion factor of
an sptff so
what is done here
is basically that we take the same
training data we just have to take we
just have to change the mechanistics
slightly in order to predict uh the the
conversion factor for different uh
serial and parallel sptff systems so
it's the same training data exactly the
same training data but what we learn
here is basically you see the
experimental data so the test
experimental data in are these dots and
the model prediction is basically are
these lines so you see how the
conversion rate depending on one two
three membranes and the feed flow rate
basically changes and this is already
done asset from the initial scouting
from the data set initially so you can
really predict the uh the conversion
factor from a certain membrane
combination based on very limited amount
of training data and this is the
advantage for example if you have in the
manufacturing side
these proteins are quite expensive and
for for sptff development you often have
to consume a lot of these materials so
finding a way how to predicting the
duration easier or faster or early on is
very helpful and here it is it's based
on a very limited amount of training
data which is then able to predict the
conversion rate for all of these
different uh different membrane types
and then you can take this for example
when you think about continuous bio
by a production you want to you have a
continuous buyer process and let's say
something in the input changes your
model basically knows if you have a
higher concentration how do you have to
adapt the feed flow how do you have to
adapt the pressure in order to get the
same uh to to change the conversion rate
in a favorable condition that you then
get the same output at the end of your
buyer processor and this can easily be
done with with such a model
so this helps you to basically reduce
development time as I said it saves drug
substance because you your training data
is quite limited you don't need that
much data compared to an ordinary sptff
development
who get much better process
understanding because all of these
curves are there and then you see okay
what what is the change of how much to
this curves change if I increase the the
starting concentration how much does
this change in order of the feed flows
all of this is basically intrinsic in
the model and as I said on the long run
it helps you also to enable advanced
process control because when you know
how these curves behave as a function of
changes in the input then you can re
revert it basically and take it for for
process control
the last thing here I want to show you
is basically Tire filtration so all of
the all of the things shown before are
already published published this is
still under development but you can see
for example
in entire filtration one of the problems
we often see is that the prediction of
the pH for example or the prediction are
of certain materials in inside inside
the solution basically is not constant
over time or over die filtration volume
and if you know for example incorporate
effects like the donut effect into your
mechanistic equations then you are also
able to describe this Behavior
and then you already know how many Tire
filtration volume you would take in
order to hit the certain pH or in order
to hit a certain recipient concentration
and these models can also help you
help you to achieve this goal term
Okay so
to summarize basically uh everything I
showed you so far is it's really
important that you consider the whole
workflow rather than just the modeling
approach it's really about thinking
about what do you want to do with your
models what are their experiments I need
to do and then thinking about the
modeling approach and not just putting
the modeling approach in the first in
the first line
nevertheless Hybrid models are sound
bases to create a process model and
digital twins in silico optimizations
what I showed you with this mdoa
approach and this then helps you
significantly to save experimental
effort resources Manpower etc etc
you can take these Hybrid models also
for process scaling and you can take
these Hybrid models then for process
control so while in the Upstream for
example you can use it for monitoring
purposes quite easily in the downstream
you could use as I showed you with this
filtration topic you can take this type
of models in order to understand or in
order to change process parameters to
get always the same concentration at the
end of an sptff approach for example
finally if you're interested into using
this tool yourself you can basically use
your smartphone just just make a photo
of this um
of this app you can download this this
toolbox basically and start modeling for
free with this tool in order to describe
your your process as much as possible or
as best as possible and to save time
finally I'm at the end of my
presentation I want to thank you for
your time if you have any questions you
can always reach out to me on on
LinkedIn or just write me an email and
then we can have a discussion about if
you have any questions any modeling
questions or any other questions I'm I'm
happy to help you thank you very much
for your time and have a great day bye